you
29 was it hmm
I'm staying away from the Dutch my
pony's saying the stream is muted we'll
see about that
let's try this BOGO BOGO or NIMS Oh none
of the above
benoni who plays the Benoni those who
are aggressive my opponent is playing
this like they know it really really
well they know more than me about this
opening I don't this is a rare rare case
that I'm playing this so I play here
give up my bishop for the night my
opponent does have a space advantage
because of this guy I'm assuming h3 will
happen right away and then jump a knight
and I don't know let's put some pressure
on this pawn know that I've lost a
minute hmm all right let's get rid of
him
h3 I want to do this thing Knight d7 to
e5 oh so much for that let's let's throw
a question this Bishop what are you
really doing are you gonna take me or
not I want to know I need some more
information about K I got the
information I wanted now I'm gonna go
with this night because I want my bishop
to see the world now I'm gonna chop here
and more trades are happening which I
believe is a good thing
so I had this bishop but but he's not
going anywhere just yet is he I'm
thinking about a six c5 I don't know
what that is really doing Queen b6 would
just be looking for tricks I'm
anticipating f4 let me let me do this
trying to expand with b5
I think f4 is not correct because I
could take and then play b5 getting my
majority going my opponent is having
none of it
so let's do this oh wait whoa whoa I
almost made a very bad move I need to
take him I was forgetting that the
bishop had a retreat square that was
silly ah
why didn't I see that the bishop could
back him up I have control over this
square this is very important sometimes
this advance will come anyhow with F 4 e
5 if I take the b f5 it's a common pawn
sacrifice to really rattle the the
coordination of my pieces okay that's
not being played in because it's not I
can make use of this square and sink my
knight deeper into the white position as
a result and by that I mean I'll play C
4 and then this is a wonderful outpost
and he's bound to do some serious damage
let's see if I'm right
c4 Knight d3 would come with tempo
against b2 and now it's coming with
tempo against the rook do I play it
right away I don't see why not
let's go there what's this cleanup - I
play g4 now that's I like that idea
how about
that's gonna be undermined isn't it let
me um move faster than I am
let's move a lot faster than I am you I
don't even know what I want to do
alright I pass that's my way of passing
I don't know what to do let me just pass
that move I should have come up with
something better than King age seven
don't you think what a pathetic move I
don't know what to do let me just tuck
my King in he seems cozier on aged seven
okay I have this check but what's what's
my follow-up oh this is what my idea was
I wanted this diagonal open up first
before so sorry oh so I would have this
sort of thing going on I could kick that
night away he's not gonna be too happy
about things is he where is he going now
Wow my opponents flying let's do that I
want to trade Queens I've could oh okay
my seventh rank is vulnerable I want my
I want to get here okay this is good
all of a sudden this this exchange
benefited me so in other words it was
better to maintain the tension Queen
here is not available for a second I was
thinking white could be converging on
that square and now she does have some
pressure there Bishop here though let's
do that and it's difficult for them to
get there
rooks working Queen there huh let's do
this let me develop my queen and hit the
rook the Queen has pressure on this pawn
rook here minute twenty five whoa really
I can't be right can it I just need to
activate
who's gonna argue with that move it's a
it's an open file Wow
I wish my opponent would slow down a
little bit so I could type to reevaluate
this changes of the position slow down
would you
I was reluctant to bring my rook the
rook on a over to the F file cuz he does
have a job watching over at a6 I just
want to double up double up on the F
file that night just get out of there
please
maybe it's oh the Queen is tied down to
the defense of the night so there is no
capture here Queen here actually Queen
here with rook here why am I not moving
fast
oh this work Oh let's get my clean here
that nights you can't go too far I want
to just pick up this pond
okay I think things are looking very
good now I'm starting to see the light a
little bit clearer here
oh that's defended offer a queen trade
my favorite that this is yeah why can't
get out of this pin so easily so now we
do this offer a queen trade and then
pick up this pawn Knight here I kick it
away
I want to force white into taking my
queen so I'm not here to defend the
Queen I don't take the Queen but rather
attack the defender of the Queen the
Queen takes pawn
I could take here and I always move up
here if there's a check Queen takes pawn
queen takes be queen check here okay so
this is what I was just talking about I
attacked a knight and this will be
winning cuz one two three
I'm there in time plenty of time so take
b7 take B to play to be won and then
advance pawn push here I take let's just
make sure okay I'm threatening this
right away oh he's there in time why did
I allow that
that was stupid ah
man I don't want to give him up so
easily though oh I get to advance that
was very helpful
oh I was gonna have a tough road ahead
my opponent forgot about that he had to
play King King to see one or night here
one of those two moves but not
night-night there oh why did I miss
calculate that I what I wasn't gonna be
able to Queen so easily with my rook
move it's a miscalculation in my part
all right good game let's let's back up
here I don't know if I played the
opening right I don't play this opening
I hardly ever I wonder if you could
insert a ch3 I think it's maybe still
okay that you are allowing me to play
this move I think what's better than
developing the bishop is as soon as I do
play this move throw a question to it
recapture with the Queen and then when
I'm threatening to play to e5 you you
maintain your LightSquared bishop key
make sure you keep that light square
bishop now it's a little bit trickier
since it happens one move later
able to exchange a couple pieces which
again is going to be helpful to me since
I have a space disadvantage so instead
of Bishop g5 I'm sure there's probably
some things earlier but this is one
thing that I could be pointing out I
think and as soon as I pin the knight
throw a question to him with age three
just as I did with h6 I wanted to learn
a little bit more about your bishops
intentions you could do that with h3 so
we have these exchanges and I
miscalculated here I for some reason I
was thinking your Bishop is stuck
couldn't it couldn't go anywhere anyhow
so I'm not gonna take it but you could
play to see - I don't know I was blind -
a simple retreat like that I was with a
six I was thinking not only to expand
but take away maybe a bishop move here
to you know get out of the line of fire
with Knight takes Bishop but you should
back up and now this becomes an issue
because f4 is the move that I have to be
most concerned about in this avalanche
of pawns f-4e five that's really your
pawn break idea you backup and f4 all of
a sudden comes with tempo yeah so
instead of a four maybe you should back
up I would get my pawns rolling that is
a downside if you backup I do get this
my majority going but I think you're the
better side
I don't have everything becomes clogged
up if you could if you could picture
this right here if I play b5 and you
play f4 hang on
Bishop c2 I play b5 you play f4 my
knight has to play here and then my
whole queen side is stuck I can't get
him out I'd end up having to play Knight
f8 97 and I think this idea of once you
have this f4 e 4 structure I think this
idea of a 5 after a capture then to play
f5 is very strong that that advance
messes with my King side structure the
safety of my King becomes a bit more of
an issue and on top of that a new square
is granted for your knight that's a
that's on c3 currently at 45 soon as
you're doing a 5 your knight as a new
home and as soon as I capture in this
direction this pawn increases in value
he becomes passed if you're making this
pawn flinch he's no longer around on the
D file so just some quick points there
this this was already a very critical
position instead of a4 consider Bishop
to see to maintain that Bishop we didn't
get there and I think you really do at
this point have to stop my knight from
getting to e5 it's just too much once
he's on e5 he's getting to d3 that's way
too deep and there's bound to be big
trouble around the corner so f4 instead
of rip to e2 is what I'm getting at
don't give me 95 and it's trouble how
could I have done better I'm pretty sure
I'm much better in this position right
now I said during the game it was bet it
was better for me when you captured so I
think you should be maintaining the
tension don't give me a file to play
with your rooks are kind of stuck as
well as your knight you have pressure on
that square I probably should have done
something different I think my bishop
can't there's not a better Square maybe
bring my queen
and defend develop a peace and meet your
threat that would have been a better
frame of mind for me to be in if you can
meet that's rat by developing and I
could have it was at least worth
considering Queen to h4 we had this I
don't know why I guess you see that the
night was so annoying gave up the
exchange got a pond for it but um I
don't know if there was something there
must have been something better by he is
tough to work around one thing one
worried that I did have is b3 to try and
undermine the night you can't you can't
do it right now because I do have
pressure on the rook but given the time
why I think should at least look into
this undermining of my night support on
d3 by playing b3 I didn't quite get
there and how could have I done better
what was the better way to convert this
to a full point I think this is still
correct and I'm pretty sure this is
still good oh you know what
rook here one two three one two three
you're there in time hang on how did
this play out rook here came there I
take King there yeah um you know what
would be better I think at least instead
of playing rook to b8 right away I think
playing to c8 one force the night here
and then I could always play here here
and then here in three moves instead of
going after this pawn rook c8 forces
night here rooks e4 to d4 to d1 and
that'll that'll be the cleanest approach
I guess they're my last worry would be
is there a way for you to get this pawn
rolling that would involve a pawn sack
but I could also just give up on the
idea of trying to
skort this pawn and capture and then go
after the deep on if you are playing E 5
but that would have I think better been
a cleaner way rook c8 Knight c1 rook c4
d 4 d 1 and that's going to be lights
out by having my rook on the d1 square i
shoulder off your king from defending c1
square whereas if i try to go about it
by getting 2 b1
your king can make use of the DS the d
file or the D 2 square okay let me close
out of this good game arm
you